need something and mute now if you live
in the bay area or the Big Apple James
or Megan could be waiting to answer your
call I just got an order for apple
lightning USB cable JBL charge portable
bluetooth speaker so looks like i'm
going to bed side they are shopping
valets for ebay now ebays newest
addition to the online marketplace in
its experiment in instant delivery
customers in San Francisco San Jose New
York Chicago and Dallas can purchase
select products from nearby retailers in
an ebay now valet delivers the goods in
under an hour mobiles change consumer
expectations around immediacy now people
can shop anytime anywhere on mobile
phones and immediate delivery is really
just a logical extension ebay charges
five bucks for the delivery service but
this holiday season it's waving that fee
in the hopes to gain more shoppers we
know that working professionals really
like the service we feel over half of
our usage between nine and five during
the day immediacy is not a new trend in
e-commerce google has its own Express
shopping service amazon is building more
Supply centers closer to cities to
reduce shipping times and Amazon CEO
Jeff Bezos says his company is testing a
program where drones will deliver
packages up to five pounds in just 30
minutes so eBay is upping the ante
expanding its ebay now delivery service
to 25 cities next year the retailer's
love that we are able to help them take
advantage of their existing stores and
meet consumers increasing expectations
when they win we win